brought you on because you finished the
Last Guardian correct yeah both did
Peter and I yeah we want to talk about
the Last Guardian because Pete you
reviewed it you gave it a 9 out of 10
you really love this game despite a lot
of shortcomings which you you know like
the people sitting around in the office
like it sound like you're frustrated
most the time but then after you know we
really don't know what you thought about
the game and you like can't say enough
good things about it yeah what is it
about this game that you can't like
you're glowing about uh it's pretty
simple it's Treecko just to throw the
bomb out there like I mean it is to me
the most believable character in a video
game ever be that human or animal and a
lot of that comes down to the way you
interact with it and the how that works
sometimes and how it doesn't work other
times it's it's weird to credit a game
for being frustrating and I don't want
to harp on that too much because I don't
think that that is really a thing worth
rewarding but I think the entire like
scope of Treecko and how you go about
your adventure with him that's that's a
part of it and the adventure as a whole
is just incredible because you you start
off with this beast that you don't
understand that you're really impressed
by and then by the end of the game you
know after all these trials it's your
best friend and you guys have been
through a lot
you've changed as Carrie well Treecko
changed the most but but I guess you the
player kind of changes you know like I I
brought a lot of myself into the
relationship as you guys know I tend to
fly off the handle at times and end
point lately no comment and Treecko
brought that out of me you know and when
I was talking to Mary initially like her
reaction was more that she felt that she
could be patient with him where I maybe
could only do that for a few minutes
before I just you know I felt like there
was some serious things going on but the
serious things going on was that I was
in a rush and I wasn't actually taking
the time to get to know how he acts and
how he reacts to me which is very very
important obviously you don't want to
you can't speak for the developers do
you think any that was intentional or do
you think this was like flaws in the
game like this frustration that you felt
I think it's a mix of both I think it's
primarily an
channel I mean no way to spoke for
himself when he said that Treecko will
not respond to you the first time all
the time okay and there is sort of a
there seems to be a progression there
and at some point in the game it's sort
of like hinted at that like hey maybe
you have more control over him now than
you did before but actually replaying
the game starting from scratch I noticed
that everything I had learned about the
way he behaves at the start of the game
that benefits how you work with him
already so it's in there and I think
it's intentional when the game has like
technical blips or maybe his tail
doesn't fall the right way and you can't
get him to like move to get it to fall
word should you might not be able to
determine the next step in a puzzle
mm-hmm and because there are so many
like false paths or solutions in this
game where you think you've identified
something you don't know if it's right
but you need Treecko to help you figure
that out when those technical blips
happen that's definitely not intentional
and that feels kind of shitty but but
again I've I've never felt so connected
to a character in a video game yeah when
you were first your first beaten and you
were like writing in the process of
writing a review you kept talking over
in the office saying like you would
start a sentence to be like this is
gonna sound hyperbole or cliche but like
again like this is seriously the most
connect I've ever been no character this
is like it I think you use like the term
like living breathing or something
similar we don't like to use but you
said in this case is actually the apt
and yeah I know you were you were kind
of like stumbling over yourself like no
seriously I really got attached to
Treecko and I want to go back and play
the game just to experience that again
for all the the weird things that come
from your cooperation if you just focus
on what Treecko does and how he acts he
never really like clipped like well
maybe he'll clip but like he'll never
like glitch out or like his AI never
seems confused like it's he it's just so
convincing the fact that he doesn't care
what you want it doesn't feel like the
game is doing it by mistake and it's
endearing because he's doing something
very cat-like or doglike and being a pet
owner I think makes me a little bit
biased but I think a lot of us even if
we don't own a pet can relate to what it
means to connect with an animal and I
really felt a connection with him that's
good yeah you have to I've heard I
unfortunately have not played any of it
yet I downloaded this morning didn't
have time but you have to like pet him
to calm him down sometimes after he like
like was defending you from guards or
attacking guards are being attacked
and marry you worse I think you had in
general more maybe there's more of a
patient person than like Pete and like
myself I'm not looking forward to the
frustration that you guys have described
to me that can rear its head but you
seem to have a pretty positive
experience throughout the entire thing
if I'm not mistaken yeah I think it's
possible that it might be my
understanding of the developers series
as a whole I played a lot of shadow
Colossus and Aiko's one of my favorite
games of all time and those games are
also very they're all in the same vein
which is environmental based puzzles
where your goal is not always clearly
defined I remember vividly I told Peter
this we were talking about the game that
I hated ICO for the first two hours I
hated it I couldn't wrap my mind around
and understand what was trying to tell
me to do I was really confused and I
think it was almost like a switch in my
brain like learning another language
when I started to realize this is the
puzzle the puzzle is figuring out what I
do next and how I deal with these
situations these frustrations so an ICO
like you're constantly pulling this girl
that can seem really frustrating that
you're constantly just helping this
helpless girl this is a part of the
bonding experience between this
character
similarly inch in in this game when when
you're talking to - Treecko and he's not
listening you can easily get frustrated
and say it obviously like this game
isn't doing what I want it to do but
it's really more about coming to terms
with the fact that you don't always get
what you want sometimes this is because
you haven't done it the correct way you
haven't talked to him you haven't coaxed
him sometimes you're actually doing the
wrong thing and you just haven't come to
terms with that yet you don't realize
that you actually need to go through a
different corridor in order to get him
to be propped up on the correct pillar
that you need so this is about
experimentation it is a bit of trial and
error but most importantly I think it's
about exploration both of your
environments and figuring out what
you're working with where you're meant
to go and both exploration of yourself
and this character that you're dealing
with
it's amazing to me I I can get
frustrated too
and I did there were times when I was
like I don't know what to do try go
you're being a real Butthead right now
he's just scratching his ear I know I'm
supposed to jump up here I often found
that it was something I was doing and
that's really reflective right when you
get frustrated with someone and then you
realize oh yeah it was me I find that I
I find these games really meditative and
really reflective on Who I am I want to
be the kind of person that that listens
and then uses that to progress the next
area I think this game is very rewarding
and in that aspect that's why I wanted
to play it again yeah it was sort of the
the take away at the end of my review is
that having learned to care so much
about Treecko and remembering all the
times that I was just belligerent
because I wasn't letting I just didn't I
didn't I took him for granted basically
right I was looking at him as a mechanic
rather than like a companion a prop to
get you to a certain place yeah please
yeah so knowing you know developing the
relationship I did I wanted to go back
and do it all over again right it's like
you know you regret an argument with
people you regret overlooking something
or taking anyone for granted and you
want to change it and like that's how I
felt about this game and so going back
and starting over it was like one I got
to hang out with him again which is
awesome but I got to also feel like I'm
gonna be a better friend this time I'm
gonna figure out how I can give Treecko
what he deserves because he over the
course of the journey changes to not
only fight for himself or work for his
own interests but to work for yours and
to get past his own hang-ups to do so
and you grow to appreciate that and you
think man if he can do that for me what
can I do for him he has for the focus of
the game obviously and like a major you
know asset of it is the relationship
between the boy and Treecko but of
course when I think back I'm not like
ego or Shadow of the Colossus there is
an overarching story that isn't
immediately apparent especially in
Shadow of the Colossus like there's no
point in like spoiling or anything but
like stuff happens later on that kind of
sheds light on what you were doing and
gives it new context and shadow Colossus
is one of my favorite games if not my
favorite game and I love that without
spoiling anything obviously was there
anything in the Last Guardian like does
the story go somewhere or is it really
just it focused on this like finite
relationship is there a broader story at
play or like would you think of that the
narrative in general there is a broader
story it's what you're not given much to
begin with and what you get at the end
is
the information that provides context
and then a like the next step in that
journey which is like the culmination of
everything you've done
which seems super interesting I mean
like earlier in the show airs talking to
Scott and he said like debt rising and a
lot of games are the opposite exposition
dump right away so you have contact you
know you do and then just play the game
like why 20 hours right whereas this I'm
hoping just like shadow Colossus or eco
which I both like love both those game
just less Guardian will build towards
something and kind of lend context to
what I've done and not what I'm about to
do it's a more it's a more natural way
of experiencing something because in
life we don't get primers ahead of an
unexpected event you know that we have
to deal with we as we meet challenges
head-on as they come and we tackle them
and yeah yeah yeah they're notorious
you're right for their world building
for taking you to these unbelievably
rich worlds where you don't really know
very much but as the story progresses
you learn that they don't play by our
world's rules and this game is no
exception there's other rules that you
don't know that you will learn along the
way that really help create this rich
world that you want to learn everything
about and it kind of just trickles
information to you piece by piece but it
really truly is a fascinating world that
you want to learn more about and even
when the game is over like I wish there
was so much more that I could learn it's
a really fascinating area and just like
their previous games I think you'll find
everything you learn about that world is
pretty pretty interesting yeah I do want
to touch on you know the running joke
lately has been we've been waiting so
long for Final Fantasy 15 and Last
Guardian now like it's a one-two punch
we have both of them within two weeks
and there's a reviewer you don't take
the development process in to play with
your opinion of the game right it's what
is the game in itself but I'd be remiss
if we didn't talk quickly about like
this game has been in development for
just as long as Final Fantasy 15 if not
a little bit a little bit long less long
look like almost a decade maybe yeah
it's super yeah roughly it is it's I
don't even know like what I want to ask
but it's just crazy that we have this in
our hands finally and like I know it
started its life as a ps3 game you know
like shadow Colossus kind of like close
out their ideas to life cycle like
I don't know what's it like do you think
like this feels like a ps4 game in
Toller does it show that this began its
life so long ago or if you didn't know
that would you notice right no if I
didn't know that I don't think I would
notice there's not many artifacts in the
game that I can look at and say oh yeah
that's clearly evidence of like this
project beginning phase or something
like that Final Fantasy 15 you could
look at and you could say yeah I see
like the two different phases of this
game in one game that's tied together
decent enough but but the magic behind I
was busted out of the class as Last
Guardian I think is evident because the
ps4 is able to actually give life to
something like Treecko where it's not
just you know an image of feathers
painted on his body every feather moves
independently on his body and that just
like really like adds to the realism of
the character which is so important
because it's not just the way he behaves
it is the way he looks as well and I
don't believe that that that the tech of
the PlayStation 3 could have handled all
that independent what seems to be
physics based animation and yeah like
there are a few scenes that that do have
some slowdown and so like but even those
scenes don't have it's like more like
lighting than anything else so like I'd
be shocked to see what this game looked
like on PlayStation 3 I don't think it's
anyway it would have worked
no you look at some of the scenes that
are later on you talk about like vast
open vistas you read that yeah if
there's like pop in you lose it yeah you
can see like things really far off in
the distance important things sometimes
where they're trying to hint at things
and really fine thin wires that you're
kind of precariously balancing on and
all that stuff in these giant open
scenes with incredible lighting effects
and some of the best if I've ever seen
grass and leaves in a game clone yeah
that are just incredible with the way
they move with the wind I mean you're
not just talking about you know Treecko
is something to be commended I think
that's true but in general I think this
is one of the most beautiful games
that's like out it is it's just stunning
what they've done to it and I think it
could have only been on the ps4 at this
point awesome yeah so as the Last
Guardian finally on our hands
about ten years but Pete Browns full
review is up on gamespot.com he gave in
nine out of ten he loved this game
despite a few frustrations but you know
years almost over and this is one seems
like it's very well worth playing you
can go read the full review and leave
your thoughts in the comments below
[Music]